later this month clark county is  starting its coronavirus vaccine pilot  program it pays you a hundred dollars to  get vaccinated it starts september 18th  and the 19th over at el dorado high the  first 500 people to show up get a 100  gift card clark county says it could  expand the program if there's a good  turnout now if you're looking for more  specific information and deeper details  on the coronavirus we have compiled all  that information in one handy place just  point your smartphone nurse your camera  at the qr code on your screen right now  go to the link that pops up that takes  you to our website we have a number of  helpful resources and other information  listed for you to check out